do things that you've said to us in the
past is that you're not comfortable
handing over the duties of screening
films to an intern even though it means
a very overwhelming amount of time and
work that you have to put in a watch
every film I know you guys got so many
submissions and it's increased
dramatically over the years so after
eight years why is that so important to
you still that you both you and Theo
play such a vital role in watching
college you know it's a possibly enjoy
it you know I mean let me tend to
forgetting to anything else it's it's
fun we love movies so you know it's a
good time to watch it's a kind of fun
like it's a cool process like to sit
down you don't know what you're gonna
see like every year we don't know what
the hell are we missing now you can see
you know you see the synopsis read the
stuff but now you put them on you're
going to find something every year
something new refreshing the school
thing about these shorts feature films
made for two things one are made for
different reasons right I mean you know
they're made for distribution to sell
commercial viability you know where it
is shorts are not so much I mean they
have changed with all the different
platforms and distribution or whatnot
and online but still the short film is
still more of a calling card is your way
of telling the story you want to tell or
a unique story it's a different kind of
medium it's different filmmaking it's
different genres so I it's not the right
right work but it's different altogether
so making shorts if filmmaker has a
different latitude of creativity whereas
you know the feature film they're made
for you know those more specific reasons
it more even again business sense what
right it's like it's been there made it
again to sell or you know for
distribution or just you know for that
that with that in mind especially the
money you're spending the time just and
you know with a short you can make maybe
a really cool short a few days just a
feature film is not some little two day
process so you know what was shorts
that's the cool thing so for us to sit
down to watch these films you know we're
finding you know really cool voice is a
new creativity like everyday we said on
a watch know much of films and so that's
one part of its enjoyment of that you
know they kind of find something new you
know it's just you watch films all day
you spend a whole day watching movies
and maybe nothing is really hitting your
very disappointed and you know they're
not going well you know the judging
process you have that
the film's a lot of submissions down
that of course not all of them are
getting in and then you see that one
film was just like just a while you know
it just kind of hits and that's that's
really neat to kind of feel like you
found it you know it's like the kind
you'd only haystack kind of I guess
metaphor or whatever but that's part of
it but to you know we want to know what
we're coming up you know what is coming
away we want to know what we have I mean
it's still our thing as our festival
it's our name behind right so it's
important for us to know what we're
screening and no ever kind of
essentially everything you know if we
come out there we're at the festival I
don't want to be there so you know I
don't know what these movies are anybody
that could be the case right if I passed
a bunch of stuff on we didn't see
anything I've never got a chance to
watch some of these films hypothetically
maybe we would never watch some of these
films you know we don't want that to
happen right i mean we want to know what
we're training we want to feel any kind
of certain relationship to that film and
the filmmakers when you meet them it's
kind of like oh you made this and then
we kind of have a kind of hit it off
already you can I know you feel like you
know them or something it's a cool
feeling it's like a I saw your film I
liked it a lot we're excited program it
we picked it because these reasons you
can talk about it it is that's how you
engage more if you didn't do that this
is like yeah I don't even yeah thanks
for being here it's great but I don't
even know anything about your movie
that's the other side of that so I think
that's fantastic that's drastic you know
um but it's not like you know we're
going to not see the film at all but
maybe we wouldn't we didn't what if you
didn't watch it in programming some some
other judge said oh this is great you
should program this business and we
never watch the films with everything
else going on we put it we program and
we do our duty we do our stuff get the
information from them be the website
ready schedule do our stuff comes home
the festival time we never seen a movie
what you don't want that to happen
really much at all if at all we want to
be able to know all the films and see
all the film's I experienced it you know
I guess the same lean audience would and
again this is art fest with our name
behind it we you know we've started this
so we want to kind of maintain that like
its integrity if nobody the right might
be the right word I mean you know we
want to maintain that we want to be able
to say we know these found
these are the ones we picked you know
and not just us alone of course we have
other members injury I'll watch with us
not just us two but what we want at
least watch with them as well and see
pretty much everything that's that's
really why you no want to feel like we
know what we have on our hands you know
that's really that i guess so i guess
it's partly also a trust factor i guess
and we yeah I guess so just trust
ourselves more than others sometimes I
guess as well
you